I read your file
you're a very troubled young woman
believe it or not I'm here to help you
you know when you put your hand out of
the window of a moving car you can feel
the air and guide it I can push the air
together water to other stuff you
thought you out of some do I can teach
you this dude thank you for meeting with
us of course I understand you have some
concerns about your son
Andy and I have always been very close
but we believe he is being bullied and
look who's here
so it's very good time my stupid earth
crazy
maybe I care about Andrew and Lauren
aware that there was a bit of an
incident at the school to see them go I
need you to go get him for me they're
not going anywhere
we have to secure the safety of the
community what is that
pure about the mutinous those are my
kids you have to help them
I didn't tell me his power dad puts
people like in jail my experience things
changed it's your own kid there's
nothing more important to me that my
family the x-men the Brotherhood we
don't even know if they exist anymore
I suggest you think about what's best
for your family what do we do it's going
to be alright
go down
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a burden yes but so I guess
[Music]
tell me about Lorna the information I
have these yours well my family is safe
you
you